it's my great pleasure to welcome you to
the inaugural lecture of the Simon
initiative which CMU just announced a
little more than two months ago and I
cannot think of somebody more
accomplished and more qualified to
deliver the inaugural lecture than dr.
Carl Wyman who's currently professor of
physics and professor of education at
Stanford University now the Simon
initiative was very carefully named
after CMU's own herb Simon whose work
over many many decades right here has
influenced the thinking on campus on how
to bring in the latest in technology and
even before the technology becomes
popular how do we make sure that we take
the latest in technology define the
cutting edge of the technology so that
it also brings in the human element in
the most appropriate way to have the
maximum impact and output in the context
of education and learning and Simon had
such a profound impact on the way in
which basic research which is
scientifically grounded and
evidence-based is is done conducted in
the most rigorous way possible so that
we can benefit from it as we employ
technology in the context of education
it is so critical as access to
information has become so widespread all
over the world and in my own thinking as
I started to meet with large numbers of
faculty on campus since summer of last
year I was thinking about how to frame
CMU's unique not only aspirations but
set of accomplishments over many decades
we have an opportunity to first consider
the individual within the context of
scaling how do we take an individual
with very different backgrounds if
individuals with very different
backgrounds how do we employ the
technology so that those individuals can
maximize and optimize the learning
outcome for themselves so somebody who
is highly accomplished with the right
background right right prior knowledge
of the field how can they learn as
quickly as possible using technology at
the same time somebody coming from an
underprivileged background for or may
have some learning disability how do we
make sure that they also have access to
the latest technology in the right
possible way so individual by individual
how do we employ technology so that it
has the maximum output outcome that's
one goal if we can do that for tens of
millions of individuals simultaneously
across national borders and
institutional borders that's even a
great greater outcome so that's sort of
the the the spirit behind this at a
local level on campus at the national
level to create a dialogue through the
Global Learning Council and at the
global level to bring together learners
and teachers so that we can develop best
practices metrics and eventually the
ingredients of standards that will have
global impact and we cannot have we
could not have asked for a better group
than the 12 members who have joined the
Global Learning Council as part and
parcel of this this vision that we now
call Simon initiative on campus and one
of the members of the Global Learning
Council is also dr. Cole Wyman now Simon
in his work in many different
disciplines on campus from business to
economics to policy to computer science
to machine learning to psychology has
had such a profound effect and he of
course was recognized in 1978 with a
Nobel Prize in Economics and we thought
it'll be most fitting to name this
initiative after him now I had the
pleasure and privilege of working with
Carl Wyman for the last three years in
Washington when I was director of the
National Science Foundation called came
rough
at the same time as the associate
director in the Office of Science and
Technology Policy in the White House in
charge of education and research in that
capacity we had an opportunity to
interact on many many occasions and we
had a standing dinner once a once a
month so we tried out different
restaurants in Washington DC and we had
an opportunity to talk about a lot of
things so you may know that call with
the two of his two colleagues received
the Nobel Prize in Physics in 2001 it
very rarely happens this way but it
turns out that all three of them are
good friends of mine and Eric Cornell
worked with call a Jayla in Colorado was
a co winner and Eric was an adviser to
me at the National Science Foundation
Wolfgang ketterle was a colleague of
mine in physics from MIT and just last
week in Davos I bumped into Wolfgang
four times and he was also at the CMU
reception in Davos and call of course
shared this price for those who are not
in physics the site the official
citation is given here for the
achievement of bose-einstein
condensation in dilute gases of alkali
atoms and for early fundamental studies
of the properties of the condensates so
let me translate that into English and
called received the Nobel Prize for what
are called ultra cold atoms and what so
we've been thinking about a way to
invite him to come here for the
inaugural lecture and the best time to
invite him is when we have an Arctic
vortex and so I'm we we had an
impeccable timing so I hope you noticed
that call so call is also I talked about
Arctic vortex but caller and I also
shared another experience in another
cold climate there is a theme associated
with call his research was in cold atoms
he comes here with rod at the coldest
time of the year
so this is a picture of me and call
standing in Antarctica in the week
before Thanksgiving in 2011 on our way
to the South Pole and and we arrived at
the South Pole together the day we were
there that temperature was minus 64
degrees and it doesn't matter whether
it's Celsius or Fahrenheit
the effect is the same
and it's pretty cold it doesn't matter
whether it's Kelvin either right so this
is in scarred base which belongs to New
Zealand and you can see the latitude
there this is north of the South Pole
seventy seven point five one degree
latitude south and this is in a place
called McMurdo which is part of the US
Station research station in Antarctica
this is our Travel Group so here is call
and that's me and this is the director
of the US Geological Survey deputy
deputy administrator of NASA and my
staff member from the National Science
Foundation this is the plane that takes
us to the South Pole so call is very
fond of cold climates so that's that's
what I wanted to tell you the other
major contribution in addition to his
many scientific and intellectual
contributions call has had a huge impact
at least the time that I overlapped with
him in Washington this is a report even
though we both co-chaired the National
Science and Technology Council Committee
on STEM education call was the driving
force behind producing this report which
for the first time through the White
House Office of Science and Technology
Policy brought together an inventory of
what the u.s. is spending on STEM
education policies and this was a report
that has had a lot of impact on Congress
and he was the main driving force behind
it I'll just close with there two slides
in recognition so in the last ten years
he has focused his most of his energy in
education as
firstly STEM education and the
University of British Columbia in
Vancouver established the call women
science education initiate there in his
honor that he led until he came to
Washington and this is an institute and
you can see achieving the most effective
evidence-based science education
effective science education backed by
evidence and this is essentially the
spirit behind the Simon initiative and
that's why we couldn't ask for a better
inaugural lecturer than dr. Cal Wyman so
with that call I would like to invite
you to give you a lecture taking a
scientific approach to science education
so thank you it's it it's a pleasure to
be here and you know I have I have to
say one of my probably high point or
depending on your geographical
orientation low point but still best
part of being in Washington was the trip
to Antarctica and the South Pole with
super and I'm I was gonna use my
pictures there but I don't have to he
had them already so I'll just say you
know it's a pretty ler pleasure to have
this being the lecturer at launching the
Simon initiative because while I won't
go in detail every time showing her
Simon's contributions in fact the work
he did is really the underpinnings of
pretty much all the stuff I'm going to
be talking about today and so he he
really started this whole area so I'm
gonna be talking about scientific
approach to science education and you
know this is motivated by the and has
the goal really to have all students
whether whatever career they're going
into to be able to to think about and
use science more like scientists do and
I think you know you have all kinds of
economic and basically societal reasons
why we need to achieve that now before I
get into you know the details of the of
the scientific approach to that I want
to just kind of whet your appetite with
some data you know and show you an
example here so this is looking at an
experiment measuring the amount of
learning that actually takes place in
class and so it's a comparison between
two you know real normal large classes
250 student sections teaching physics
and where they're covering an identical
set of learning objectives
gives in an identical amount of class
time and then both groups have the same
test right at the end of this and
comparison with the results between two
different instructors one of these was a
very experienced professor teaching this
many times these two high student
ratings but used to face a traditional
lecture approach the other was a person
who had a PhD in physics but a newly
minted PhD so little experience in
teaching but had been trained in the
principles of effective teaching that
I'm going to talk about today on my talk
so what was the outcome between the two
groups well it's it's this histogram
here so the this is the score the
histogram of numbers students versus the
score on this common exam and so the red
here is the results from the truth
highly rated but traditional teacher
where I should point out random guessing
gives you three on this so you can see
how much learning was accomplished in
that class versus the one using these
research-based methods in the in white
and so no this is a starting point to
convince you maybe this is worth paying
attention to
obviously something's very different
happening between these two cases and
we'll come back to some details on this
but but all this really comes about
because of late starting with the worker
for assignment but now major advances
particularly in the past couple of
decades from three different fields
cognitive psychology you know mostly
work in lab studying how people think
and learn studies of the brain and and
then studies in classrooms primarily
university science and engineering
classrooms and what's coming out of all
of these fields is is a very consistent
gins or understand
in principles for what's needed to
achieve learning of complex things like
science and and these principles then
are sort of you know guiding what we do
but before I go into showing you some of
those results and and what we're
learning from these fields I want to
give you a sense of my perspective on
this how I got into thinking about this
my own way
and starting with the way I started
teaching when I was a new faculty member
and I was supposed to teach introductory
physics and so I used what I think is
the natural human reaction when you're
had called the pun to teach anything to
anybody as I you know thought about the
material very carefully got it all
figured out in my own mind so that then
I could go and explain it to the
students so they would understand it the
same way I do and then I give them some
problem to solve the ones who do it
great and was successful if they
couldn't do the problem well there must
be something wrong with those students
because you know I clearly understood it
and just explained it to them right now
you know some teachers figured while the
students are just hopeless in that case
just get rid of them and that happens to
lots of students but you know others are
like me I was nicer so I would try
telling them again louder with the hope
this would be more effective now I've if
nothing else always been a very hardcore
experimentalist I measure believe in
measurement measuring results and you
know whenever I would make an effort to
really understand how students were
learning and thinking it was clear to me
that my brilliantly clear explanations
we're in fact leaving most of the
students quite baffled and no but I did
a few tests with some of my colleagues
students and they weren't doing any
better so you know this was just seemed
like
kind of unfortunate fact of life
frustrating but that's the way it was
she couldn't do much better now but my
enlightenment of this didn't come
through teaching in the in the formal
sense it actually came through my
research work of service you know
alluded to item substantial atomic
physics program over many years work
closely with lots of graduate students
and I came to see there was a curious
pattern that emerged so the first place
is that well pretty much all these
students they didn't get into my lay
unless they'd had you know many years of
spectacular success and course work
particularly physics coursework but in
spite of that pretty much universally
and put into the lab to do research they
were preclude us about what to do but
that was only you know that wasn't maybe
so surprising what was really surprising
is consistently though was after a
couple years of working in the research
lab they had turned into expert
physicists now the first few times I saw
this happening you know al I thought it
was just kind of an idiosyncrasy z' of
those students but after enough years
and enough students and Kimsey this is
really quite a consistent pattern there
had to be some underlying reason for
this you know that there's a there's a
fundamental puzzle about learning
involved here now you know first
hypothesis was you know you know that
occurs to me and lots of people have
seen this as well maybe the human brain
it just needs sort of to go through sort
of like a 17-year caterpillar stage
before it can blossom into a physicist
butterfly but I took a little more
scholarly approach to seeing if that was
really true and so I dug into research
on how people learn learning some of
herb Simon's work and how they learn
physics and from that I came to see that
in fact
the this wasn't a puzzle at all if you
look at the research a completely
explain why this was happening and it
gave me a completely different way to
think about learning and it showed how
we can really do much better and how we
teach our classes particularly college
science classes and so you know that's
what I'm going to tell you about
starting with sort of the the highest
level picture of this at really the
whole paradigm on on learning of complex
tasks with the research is really
telling us maybe we have to think about
in a new way and then the the old way
and it's really the way I used to think
about and unfortunately still reflected
in most of the current teaching is that
you know we have coming into our
classrooms these brains and they have
variations in them we immerse them in
knowledge in our teaching and it soaks
into variable amounts depending on how
that brain started but what the research
is tying is the new paradigm is really
that these brains come into our
classrooms not being all that different
and really they transform actually
change through suitable exercise and to
the extent their brains are doing
they're going the same kind of exercise
they can all change in much the same way
and that's really what learning is about
so next I want to sort of dig down a
little more deeply into this is you know
I talked about learning what is it that
we really want students to learn when I
say I want them to think you know more
like a scientist does you know an
obvious they're not gonna become expert
scientists about move in that direction
of thinking more like a scientist what
does that really mean okay and then what
do we know about how its learned and
then look at some data from classrooms
testing these ideas so the first is you
know what does it mean to think like a
scientist or what does it mean to
actually to think like an
expert in any field and this is where
herm Simon did much of the pioneering
work but cognitive psychologist over the
years have advanced this a long ways and
they've learned a great deal about the
characteristics the nature of expertise
and how that expertise is acquired and
it turns out they found it's quite
consistent over many many different
human endeavors
so expertise or expert competence has
three basic components or universally
the first one everybody could guess
experts in their field that have a know
a whole lot of information about that
field the others aren't so obvious and
in some ways more important from an
educational standpoint but the second is
that experts in any any specific field
they have a particular organizational
framework by which they you know
mentally they organize all this
information and this organizational
framework of of the discipline makes it
much more allows them to be much more
effective at deciding which event that
information is useful and applying it
quickly and effectively and these kind
of mental organizational frameworks are
involved you know looking for in
recognizing certain complex patterns and
relationships and most of what we talked
about of scientific concepts is the way
scientists in a given field to have a
whole bunch of different pieces of
organiz information that they organize
together and so that they can see oh
yeah this is going to be useful or not
and it's a great filter for dealing with
USand of knowledge then the third
general characteristic of expertise is
experts in in working there fair always
able to actually analyze their own
thinking so a person an expert is
working in a problem they're they're
continually are running this background
testing asked question aim of
do I understand this is this really a
sensible way to be solving this problem
and they have resources that they are
calling upon that can actually answer
those questions and then guide changes
accordingly to be effective problem
solving now what the research tells us
is all of these but you know I want to
focus particularly on these two are
fundamentally new ways of thinking
no human brain you know starts out
having these in any area of endeavor and
research shows is that everyone requires
many hours of intense practice to
develop these and actually to get to a
high level of expertise as it's Tim's
great Universal requiring many thousands
of hours and nowadays I think it's
becoming quite clear that the you know
the reason for this is fundamentally
biological that in the participant to
have this kind of expertise you have to
basically substantially change the brain
that change the wiring in the brain and
you know it just takes a lot of time and
exercise to get the brain to work
through to do that now the next aspect
of want to type general learning about
expertise is not just the the general
characteristics
okay so okay so sorry it affected my
train of captured my train of thought so
saying it takes as many thousand hours
of intense practice but it's not just
any kind of practice very specific kinds
of practice are needed the learner has
to be tackling challenging but not
impossible tasks or problems you know
things that are hard exercise their
brain strenuously but they can still
make progress on them and those tests
have to be very explicitly practising
the expert thinking tasks or activities
that you know make up expertise in that
discipline and there has to be guiding
feedback from you know presumably a
coach or a teacher on what they're doing
right what they're doing wrong how to
get better and so you know these are the
basic components and the evidence is
that okay you just do this keep getting
better and better seeing working do more
and more difficult but possible problems
and after about 10,000 hours most people
and most subject is what the research
would suggest can read sort of a
world-class level of expertise but in
the process and I want to emphasize this
because it's important for thinking
about teaching they have quite a
different brain than what they started
out as so what's the how does the
teacher come into this well I think the
best way to think about this isn't an
effective teacher is really so like a
coach but in a cognitive sense and so
what the what a effective teacher really
has to do is first really think
carefully about what makes up expertise
in this subject and then what's a good
practice activity that we'll have that's
appropriate for the learner and have
them quite explicitly practicing that
kind of expertise and then the teacher
has to give them good good feedback
and good means both specific you know
here's what you're doing right here's
how great you need to get better and
timely so it immediately can change
their functioning and then finally this
requires you know this kind of learning
expertise it requires a lot of hard work
it's inherent and so so the a good
teacher also like a good coach really
has to worry about motivation to how'd
it convince you know these novice
students who don't know anything about a
subject obviously and therefore it can't
really be expected to appreciate why
they should put an enormous amount of
work into mastering this subject that's
the job of the teacher to show them why
this is a valuable useful you know
relevant thing to learn and therefore
worth this investment of effort to
master it now I want to just emphasize
if you think about these requirements
they really inherently require a great
deal of expertise in the discipline and
in fact they require a great deal more
expertise than it does to get up in
lecture on the subject ok and so in some
sense I see this is the fundamental
justification of research universities
it's where you have the expertise and
therefore you have the potential to the
most effective job of teaching that
expertise to others on the other end
that also makes it you know you know
research universities need to think
about the responsibility that comes to
that to make sure that they are teaching
in a way that best takes the utilizes
and transfers the expertise of the
faculty ok so I want to so these basic
principles and activities they've played
out in you know people have then studied
how to implement them in particular
subjects and particularly levels and and
canoeing testing and comparison of these
usually comparisons with the traditional
lecture approach to
teaching and there's actually a
remarkable amount of research published
on this I I you know my last review
about a year ago I turned up about a
thousand research studies on this when
undergraduate science and engineering
and we're showing that teaching methods
that utilize these principles that I
talked about consistently show greater
learning and greater student success and
things like lower failure rates and so
I'm just gonna run quickly through a few
of what you know three of the thousand
examples sort of to to illustrate this
to you so the first one looks at
conceptual mastery by that and this is
an area that's been studied a lot in
physics education research and what I
mean by conceptual mastery I mean you
come you test if the students and put in
some new situation you know examining
some new situation can recognize what
physics concepts correctly apply to make
meaningful predictions about the
behavior in that system okay and so
there's been a lot of work developing
some good tests that cover areas of
physics that allow you to see how
students are developing that mastery so
the oldest and most widely used is
something called the the force concept
inventory and it takes a little subset
of the basic concepts of force and
motion that are covered in every first
semester physics class and gives simple
real-world applications like cars
running into trucks and then sees if
students can correctly predict the
behavior there by applying the right
concepts applying like a physicist would
and the way these this is used a lot is
you you give this test to the students
at the beginning of the semester and
then you give it to them at the end
after they've completed the course
covering the
and you look at okay what fraction of
these you know what fraction did they
things they didn't know at the beginning
could they do right at the end and these
are you know key essential concepts of
the material so the class is looking at
these very directly that really you
expect all students should learn them so
this is used a great deal and it
prevented shows a very profound result
namely if I look at this sort of percent
didn't know that they actually learned
and I take the average of that over all
the students in the class it turns out
that in a traditional lecture class that
learning game never exceeds point three
in other words that the average student
in the class didn't learn as much as a
third of these essential concepts that
they didn't already know when the course
started and this is just one published
compilation of sixteen of these reside
data from many many others who look much
the same the reason this is so
compelling is that you know this this
data and the other data I have includes
courses of you know wildly varying class
sizes different types of institutions
there's Harvard University and a
community college in there and different
you know ratings of how good lecture is
so and we got other data from now from
other levels and other subjects really
just painting a compelling picture that
this traditional lecture approach is
just not an effective way to achieve
conceptual mastery on the other hand we
also have lots of data now showing that
and particularly for this material and
using this test basically their
materials now that people are pretty
much standard lis of well tested faculty
just kind of picking up but not you know
applying in their classrooms and they
pretty consistently get up into this
range so over a factor of two
improvement in
learning conceptual mastery now another
study that one of my favorites is comes
from Cal Poly and it again is looking
another half sort of a similar type of
test of conceptual mastery first-year
physics but the reason I particularly
like this is it addresses the issue of
you know well maybe in that data I
showed you then the people adopted those
are just the the special faculty who you
know had some special abilities and they
took to use these techniques in this
study they had a whole bunch of sections
and a whole bunch of faculty included
much of the department and they
basically just changed how all of them
taught they had a powerful beam what can
I say so started out that collected data
on this conceptual mastery over a number
of years and this was a different task
but the average faculty member was
getting a bit under point three which
again is quite good for a traditional
lecture approaches as they were using
and then they switch to a different
teaching method makeover studio approach
but what this was was you know all the
students instead of listening to
lectures all the students had a set of
of carefully developed by the physics
education researchers carefully develop
set of tasks problems that they worked
on in small groups and and the faculty
were then facilitators as of them
working together on this and so what
kind of results did they get after all
the faculty switched to that well so
here's here's the results the learning
gains now are up here just a factor to
be above their previous average and
there's a couple of things also they're
quite striking about this in fact all
the faculty are now the same you see
variations here but in fact you know
these are 30 student classes
you do a more detailed statistical
analysis there's no statistical
difference between any of the faculty
here they're all teaching with
essentially equal effectiveness and this
again sort of really emphasize the point
that it's really the mental activities
of the students that affect the learning
and because the students in this
structure are doing much the same kind
of mental processing they're also
achieving much the same learning and it
shows that basically every faculty
member can now be highly effective using
the right teaching practices but it you
know it's this data so it's so really
striking to see you know how much better
a given faculty can make depending on
what teaching practices they use and I
look at at this particular one here okay
so they were getting down here a little
below point one and now they're up at
point six so so that teach that remember
they just changed their teaching methods
and their students learn to factor six
more so that's really compelling to me
and I always wonder how university
administrators can look at that and say
well gosh it's okay if our faculty are
using the methods like this you know
it's not our job to make them change so
not to put you on the spot or anything
okay those are here's a you know those
are measures of learning and you know
particular kind of expert learning you
can also look at things like failures
and and dropout rates and here's work
from different field computer science at
best Simon's work at University of
California at San Diego and so she took
and this again involves a number of
instructors I think there are five
different ones involved in here teaching
sort of their base foundational for
courses here and looking at the look
into failure and dropout rates and I
particularly like computer science
because it's you know it's pretty darn
well defined
it's pretty easy to make sure your tests
year-to-year are really because you know
testing the same thing consistently and
so but they introduced what's called my
these maps it's called peer instruction
which is basically that the class
operates by the around the instructor
posing a set of questions you know
posing questions to the student the
students have clickers they to answer
them individually then they have to talk
in small groups about the question what
the answer is and why and three answer
again using clickers and so Beth had
these multiple instructors employ this
and the green then shows the the
resulting failure in' dropout rates when
they introduced this different way of
teaching the material and the average
across these classes is now about a
third of what it was if you think about
G University of California San Diego
this is a whole lot of students here who
are now you know being successful in
this class going on to be successful
careers that could well of you know
switched out of switch to different
fields or dropped out of college
entirely because of their failures okay
so the final example I'm going to use is
getting back to the one I the data I
started out with and that first make the
the point that these examples I gave
here are and really quite appropriately
and most meaningful are measuring things
that the result of the entire class you
know beginning to end involving what
happens in the classroom exam studying
for exams homework etc there's a whole
lots of learning going on and those act
it in those sorts of outside classroom
activities but because faculty spend so
much of their time when they're thinking
about teaching and the evaluation is so
focused on what happens in the classroom
we want to do a little just a little
research experiment checking on well how
much learning really takes place in the
classroom and how dependent is that on
what method
of teaching are used in the classroom so
this study was was quite specifically
designed to focus only on that classroom
learning and so it basically then took
there's a giant course that had multiple
250 student sections this was the
introductory physics for engineering
students and so now you know this was in
a great big lecture hall here so just to
show you this isn't just class small
class kind of things you can do and the
comparison that I mentioned before the
control group was this experienced
faculty member and the experimental
group was this postdoc trained to use
these principles and approaches I've
been talking about and said beginning
had exactly the same set of learning
objectives they'd agreed on to be
covered in the same amount of class time
that was also something people haven't
been too careful in studying these
things and there's a worry you won't be
able to cover as much material so we
made sure they're gonna cover exactly
the same stuff testing on this exam they
jointly develop and that was given so
they this was to be covered in one week
of class periods carefully chosen so
right after they finished an exam and
and a homework assignment and so we
could be quite confident they weren't
going to be studying anything outside of
class for a while and then right at the
end of the last class given this test
okay and so you've already seen the
results but I want to say so what was
what were the principles that this
postdoc was designing these class
activities around well first I'd say
there was no pre-prepared lecture
material so nothing in which that the
they were prepared to go in and start
talking to the students there were
pre-prepared lecture tasks and you know
for the students to start working on and
these built into these tasks were first
thinking about picking examples and
problems and presentation to motivate
the students to want to learn this
there's lots of research on best ways to
do that
you know directly looked at what we knew
about how students thought about this
this topic and so yeah tailor and
connect up with that confusions they
might have apply what's known well known
about how the mind works and learning
and processing information I'll say a
little more about that in a minute and
then finally you know think of the right
kinds of questions and problems to have
students work on in class and in this
case they used a mixture above these
type of I talked about before clicker
questions that the students answer with
clickers and talk amongst themselves and
some little worksheet activities where
again they work in small groups working
a front for chief they'd have to write
some things out solving stuff and then
this you know focus on making a of
feedback and the the idea being you know
the students get some feedback from
talking to each other
that really helps but he they also to
enhance the feedback the instructors
busy you know wandering around listening
in on those conversations and therefore
getting up even in a 250 student class
you just sampled the groups on the aisle
you're gonna they're quite an accurate
view of what things they're confused by
what they understand and so on and
therefore you're much better poised to
give them effective feedback after
they've worked on something so so you
know building these tasks with those
ideas in mind and executing them are
what gives this kind of differences in
learning that takes place in the
classroom one of the things I like to
particularly this shows particularly
well and I emphasize we it has been seen
in other research but is how this
addresses the question that lots of
people have of know does this kind of
teaching just work for the you know the
struggling students or does it work for
the the top students as well or vice
versa and you know this is
clear that this entire distribution has
moved up dramatically and so this really
makes the case that you know this type
of teaching is more effective for every
student who has a human brain which is
usually the vast majority and that's
what the research would say we're not
talking about principles that come out
of just struggling students we're
talking about principles of how the
brain learns and why this is effective
I'll just also mentioned for you know a
selling point for faculty not too
surprising if you think about it we
measured engagement in these glasses to
the engagement was dramatically higher
in the interactive class okay so I'm
just gonna wrap up here with finish with
want to give sort of a takeaway to
faculty who may be not so familiar with
these things and and so on some three
cases that you can mock out and use in
your courses tomorrow okay now if you've
been using all this stuff yeah you
probably already have this but I'm
hoping that some of you you know won't
just walk out and say gee that data is
pretty compelling but of course I don't
know what to do here's some things you
could do okay so I'm gonna give three
particular straightforward examples that
really embody these basic principles so
the first is thinking about the homework
and exam problems that you give and and
what they're doing in terms of giving
practice and assessment of expert
thinking okay so right sort of go back
and think about here is that here's a
sad of some basic really Universal
aspects across science and engineering
certainly of of expertise in the
discipline so you know as a set of
consistent concepts and mental models
and criteria for which of those you want
to use
ability to recognize relevant and
irrelevant information to solve the
problem and know what informations
needed to solve a problem like this
knowing and having criteria for deciding
if an answer is correct or not and the
process by the the process of you know
model development and use having these
set of models by understanding how to
refine and and adopt these into new
situations and then finally every field
has a particular set of specialized
representations which experts then you
move between them and it's a great help
to understanding and solving problems
okay so just that's just a reminder of
key components of expertise and now I'm
going to look at the typical homework
problem that it's you know any textbook
the back of it you know chapter homework
problems first they will always provide
all the information needed and only the
information needed to solve the problem
and if there's approximation
simplifications you neglect friction or
air resistance and so on
they clearly say that and then you know
exams all say that so you think about
that well okay so that just write down
any opportunity for students to ever
learn about or you to assess them on
those particular components of expertise
you know typically they're just supposed
to get any answer there's not any
question requiring justify why that
answers reasonable or come up with
criteria for by that answers reasonable
so that one goes away only calling you
know usually only cover one
representation so that goes away
and finally the the nature the problems
are very often such that a student can
can really just memorize the procedure
without any understanding the underlying
model and concepts but because
they you know they memorize a procedure
and they know this applies to Chapter
five problems and you immediately just
give them Chapter five problems and on
the exam all they test them on Chapter
five problems you know they can
recognize these surface features and
just apply those procedures kind of
mindlessly but quite effectively they do
well in the home on the exams and so on
butter or have no expertise means that
if they're given a new context they're
completely hopeless at doing anything
useful but so that rep wipes out those
different components of expertise so the
message to you is go back and think
about the homework and exam problems
you're giving and by the way think about
the homework problems first before
putting all these things on the exam
when students have never seen them
before okay but of of okay how do you
how do you design better problems that
really embody these elements of
expertise because that's going to help
students learn better next thing is is
just paying attention to how the memory
works in the brain so very quickly the
slightly simplified version memory can
be thought of as as having two
components there's the the long-term
memory which is what most of us think
about is memory it has this enormous
capacity and obviously and you know
retains things for years decades but
then there's the short-term working
memory this is the sort of way the mind
works for remembering and processing
things on short timescales
namely things like in a in a classroom
situation and that short-term memory is
nicely represented by this Gary Larson
cartoon it has a very limited capacity
and in fact the the research shows it's
the typical human brain can basically
remember and process something like five
to seven
distinct new items where a new item is
something that's not in long-term memory
and it's also important to realize that
that this is not just a memory it's kind
of like a CPU that it does it it's if
you give it more on new items to keep
track of it bogs down its whole
processing and so it can't really
process and learn those things as well
and so you know if you think about and
if you ever sit onion on a on a lecture
outside your discipline you realize that
this is a tiny number of new things
compared to what's presented in a in a
normal science lecture and so anything
you can do to reduce these demands on on
working memory will actually help
students learn and so you know when you
think about that common you know
technical term that you always use it
makes it easier to talk about you really
need to be thinking about though is that
really you know one-sixth of what I want
students to get from today's class
because if it isn't you better leave it
out let them go learn it outside of
class when you don't have the same time
limitations and therefore it doesn't
have such significance and so you know
it's also true for that interesting
little you know side tidbit or detail
anything that requires cognitive
processing has a real cost in what the
students can learn and so you need to
take that into account the other thing
you can do in this regard that helps a
lot there's many others but if you are
much more explicit than it's usually
done to show students how the different
ideas you're working with are connected
okay and so that that ends up in their
brain rather than living as these sort
of separate isolated independent things
that take up more working memory they
can see oh that's sort of different
aspects of one single thing
consolidating them then frees up working
memory
to to learn other things okay in that
spirit since you all have working
memories and I am seriously Chris you
know running up a limit here that I
probably exceeded I'll make sure
somebody has copies of my slides that
are easily about what you want them okay
so finally the last thing is just giving
you the think about the benefits do you
know lecture in just this assuming
you're not using clickers or anything
you've been doing lectures but just to
realize the benefits of just stopping
class for once and giving some
challenging conceptual question to the
students to sit there and talk about
okay so first it's not that important
that they can actually answer it in fact
it might be good if they couldn't
there's some reason to believe but it
just has to be something they can get
seriously engaged with and if that
happens first it gives them a chance to
sort of break in the fat flood of
information they get sort of taught as
they're talking through consolidate
organize their their thoughts that were
do you know kind of frees up working
memory they can get from each other some
immediate feedback you know for the
students who have completely lost what
the last ten minutes were about because
they couldn't remember what mitosis is
now they have an opportunist student
next to them can tell them and then
suddenly they think and start to make
sense so that's a immediate benefit and
you know they're now talking arguing to
the reasons their brains are processing
more but it also turns out that people
learn vastly more if they've been primed
to learn so if they've been struggling
with a question you know and a problem
and then you're going to explain how to
do it they learn enormous ly more than
if you give them the explanation before
they ever know what the question or
problem is there's but finally and the
one I want to emphasize the most is that
you get to listen in on those
conversations and so you'll get so much
better idea about what they understand
and therefore what you should follow up
and talk about than you ever could if
you just continued through your lecture
so so you know there's really it's a
very simple thing to do as a starting
point and you get a large immediate
penetrates okay so with that I'll just
end here we have a bunch of time for
questions and discussion and you know
just give you this this vision which I
think the Simon initiative was really a
perfect match for really thinking about
science and engineering teaching and
learning as a science as a research
discipline and it needs to be you know a
lot you know to make this more like
astronomy instead of astrology which is
well unfortunately much of our teaching
practices have developed and so I'll
make sure that slides are available and
here are a bunch of references on
implementation things and learning more
about this subject so thank you
you